the Nupes is over
the socialists and the communists have decided to stop participating
and even within La France insoumise
divisions are coming to light
last night the PS won
a on its participation in the
Nupes at the National Assembly
until Jean-Luc Mélenchon has clarified his refusal to qualify the
Hamas of land organization
it should be said that this clarification will never happen
since Jean-Luc Mélenchon is obstinate
and will not move
of its line
just like his
close circle that makes
block behind him
Sunday the Communist Party
had adopted a resolution calling the Nupes an "
and calling for "a new type of union" of the left
and environmental MPs
have announced that they will no longer participate in the Nupes intergroup
if the 4 parties of the alliance are not represented
in short that says end
of the intergroup says
end of the Nupes
since the National Assembly was the only space where the Nupes
had a concrete political existence
but for all that the
desire for union remains strong and in the majority on the left
we start
then to speak of a
" alter-nupes "
it would be a new gathering of the left
who would not be under the hegemony of Jean-Luc Mélenchon
with the socialists
environmentalists and
communists and the so-called "constructive" insubordinates
because even within La France insoumise
usually silent MPs
have risen to denounce
the up-and-down of Jean-Luc Mélenchon
and criticize the official line of the movement
this is the case of the deputy of Paris Arenas
who is the only insubordinate to have participated
in the solidarity march with Israel
but also the MP
of the Bouches-du-Rhône Hendrik Davi
who pointed the finger
"the impossibility of any democratic debate" within the movement
even MEP Manon Aubry
to lead the insoumise list to the next European elections
moved away from the official line and recognized the
Hamas as a terrorist organization
they are added to the usual insubordinate "slingers,
" namely Clémentine Autain
François Ruffin
Alexis Corbière
Raquel Garrido
and the latter even declared that Jean-Luc Mélenchon "has only done harm
for 10 months "
the rumor that runs these last days
it is the creation of an insubordinate group
simultaneously with the National Assembly
it would take at least 15 deputies for it to materialize
will they go through with this initiative
it is too early to say it but in any case it is very risky
you really have to be
sure of its blow
and especially once
that we are launched
it is impossible to
turn around